meine damen und herren wird das
präsidium über fünf millionen menschen
beziehen hierzulande eine rente von
weniger als 500 euro
was machen sie von der linkspartei sie
wollen in diesem antrag die
asylbewerberleistungen für jeden
erwachsenen auf 582 euro erhöhen
das bedeutet bis zu 250 euro mehr im
monat für jeden asylbewerber wie wollen
sie das den fünf millionen erklären die
weniger als 500 euro rente bekommen
viele viele dieser armut rentner mit
mini renten sind übrigens frauen frauen
die kinder großgezogen haben frauen die
teilzeit oder in familien betrieb
gearbeitet haben frauen die sich um den
haushalt gekümmert haben diese frauen
leben nun in altersarmut sie treten die
lebensleistungen dieser frauen mit füßen
und fordern dass man das knappe geld des
staates lieber den asylbewerbern in den
rachen werfen sollte für asylbewerber
denen wohnungen nach modernsten standard
gebaut werden für asylbewerber die schon
jetzt abermillionen der
asylbewerberleistungen jeden monat in
ihre heimatländer überweisen weil sie in
ihren unterkünften eine vollversorgung
bekommen von der viele deutsche rentner
nur träumen können
wissen sie was sie gemäß ihrer eigenen
lektionen sind gemäß ihrer eigenen
diktion sind sie nämlich sexisten sie
sind jene die das gender pay gap
vergrößern indem sie die armen deutschen
rentnerinnen mit füßen treten während
sie den asylbewerbern die hauptsächlich
jung und männlich sind das geld in den
rachen werfen was die fdp was die fdp
hier fordert das geht in die richtige
richtung ja es ist aber eine sammlung
von bürokratischen mini verbesserungen
die das problem was wir mit der
zunehmenden armut in diesem land haben
in keinster weise lösen
wissen sie warum wir so viele arme
mitbürger inzwischen haben warum
obdachlose in allen deutschen
großstädten zum stadtbild zählen warum
so viele menschen mit den
sozialleistungen nicht über die runden
kommen weil zu den realitäten gehört
dass jeder dritte bezieher von hartz iv
inzwischen ausländer ist tendenz stark
steigend
weil wir hunderte millionen kinder geld
ins ausland überweisen ebenfalls den
dance stark steigend weil asylbewerber
gesundheitsleistungen kostenlos bekommen
für die rentner massiv zu zahlen müssen
es ist wohl einmalig in der welt dass
ein staat so viel geld für ausländer in
seinem sozialsystem ausgibt wie wir das
in deutschland gerade tun sie alle hier
haben dafür gesorgt also soweit bekommen
es mit ihrer politik der offenen grenzen
durch die jeder arme der welt einfach
ins deutsche sozialsystem einwandern
konnte und immer noch kann sie haben
geld für gesorgt dass kommunen gezwungen
waren aber milliarden für asylbewerber
unterkünfte auszugeben anstatt für den
sozialen wohnungsbau
sie haben dafür gesorgt dass selbst
abgelehnte asylbewerber dauerhaft
bleiben können
gerade eben mit dem gesetzesentwurf und
über kurz oder lang anspruch auf eine
eigene wohnung hierzulande haben werden
sie haben dafür gesorgt dass für
minderjährige unbegleitete asylbewerber
wie den attentäter von würzburg mehr als
50.000 euro im jahr ausgegeben werden
während immer mehr rentner und
obdachlose im müll nach pfandflaschen
suchen sie alle hier sind für die
grassierende armut im land
verantwortlich liebe bürger schauen sie
sich einfach im land um schauen sie wie
die zahl der armut rentner der armen
menschen in allen altersklassen
zugenommen schauen sie wie viele
obdachlose wir inzwischen haben schauen
sie sich an wie vielen stellen die
politik der altparteien gescheitert ist
es geht nämlich auch anders eine
alternative steht bereit